you could be in El Salvador or Venezuela
where governments have just printed
unprecedented amounts of money your
money is now worthless so now you're
going to need something whereby it has a
limited Supply there's no centralized
Authority which can increase the supply
and also you're going to want something
which you're entirely Sovereign over so
a lot of the time in order to see a use
case in something you have to experience
the problem so you clearly haven't
experienced the problem maybe if you'd
worked 50 years of your life and you
look at your savings and you see
inflation basically like melt away your
savings use case for it